the worst alphabet book ever that's what
pterodactyl calls itself for each letter
the example word is terrible usually
because it begins with the right letter
but the letter is silent for example A
is for I'll K is for Knight D is for
Djibouti e is for you
English every letter is silent sometimes
except for one the bread Klein indict
handkerchief imagine fifth gnaw rhyme
business marijuana knife talk mnemonic
Autumn Jeopardy pneumonia lacquer voxel
Island listen build wrist faux pas
prayer Rendezvous the closest V ever got
to being silent is in 2017 when the
president of the United States tweeted
this word kofefi this this is what the
book does for V